Hillary Clinton's 2016 campaign chairman
John Podesta was one of the people
interviewed by Muller's investigators
Podesta's private emails were stolen by
russian-backed hackers and made public
during the campaign last year a grand
jury indicted 12 russian intelligence
officials on charges brought by the
special counsel in connection to the
hack John Podesta is founder of the
Center for American Progress and he's in
Washington for an interview you'll see
first here on CBS this morning welcome
John let me start with John with mr.
Muller's fire report here you said and
you said previously that you you trusted
him what do you make of his report then
well look I think he's a great
professional and and he did a thorough
investigation of this he also found that
there were a hundred incidences where
agents of the Russian government talked
to members of the Trump campaign and
there were 28 meetings he concluded
ultimately that there was not beyond a
reasonable doubt evidence of a
conspiracy and I accept that conclusion
what do you think that I think it's
important for us to see the whole report
not just mr. Bowers four page summary of
it as well what do you think the next
move should be for Democrats on the hill
in terms of you know they want to see
the rest of the report but then they
also you know can get bogged down in
this for the for the next two years of
the administration well look I think the
public has a right to know what mr.
Muller found he obviously could
conducted an extensive report and so I
think the push to make the entire report
public is completely appropriate there's
still questions that are open and there
are investigations that are ongoing in
the Southern District of New York by the
state Attorneys General of New York and
New Jersey and others so I think that
Democrats would be well to push for the
full release of the report but there are
other matters that they need to
investigate about this administration as
well as John mentioned you were
interviewed by the special counsel are
you surprised at all that the president
wasn't interviewed directly by the
special counsel we know he submitted
answered questions but he wasn't
interviewed in person yeah
that's exceptional and and I think the
question is why
you know perhaps mr. Muller will be
asked that question by this by the
Judiciary Committee why he thought he
could complete his report without being
submit to questions by the special
counsel but right now all we know is
that he did have heavily lawyer answers
submitted for the record but we but had
he been subject to you know I think I
know why his lawyers didn't want him to
be put before the special counsel
because mr. Trump has a you know
well-known inability to tell the truth
but you know we'll see we'll see where
this goes and and I think there's you
know still more to come but most
importantly I think we need to see the
whole report the four page summary
concludes the only thing that's quoted
in there is to say that he that the
special counsel did not exonerate mr.
Trump even though they didn't find that
he committed the crime of obstruction of
justice so you know let's see the whole
thing and the American public can be
judge you know can judge the for
themselves how mr. Trump conducted
himself well Professor Jonathan Law
Professor Jonathan Turley was here
earlier and he said listen it's
impossible to see the whole report some
of it will be redacted because it has
sensitive national information so we
can't as a public he said see the full
report is there merit to that well you
know look I think there might be some
classified information that that will
have to be redacted there even
conceivably is some grand jury
information and that needs to be
redacted but the bulk of the reports can
certainly be forthcoming and that's been
the precedent in the past and I don't
see why this should be different quickly
do you believe the Justice Department
acted appropriately throughout this
investigation well I think mr. Muller
acted appropriately throughout the
investigation and mr. Rosenstein had his
hands full trying to protect mr. Muller
from Donald Trump who constantly tried
to interfere in the investigation and
constantly disparaged the special
counsel
maybe he has second thoughts about that
today but I think that you know the rule
law I think needs to prevail in this
country and and most importantly I think
the public meets the the assurance that
this was thorough but the bottom line is
Russia did interfere in our election
there were indictments forthcoming they
they did try to help Donald Trump get
elected president and his national
security adviser is campaign chairman
his deputy campaign chairman it's
personal liar of all either pled guilty
or been found guilty so to call that a
total for sure all right John Podesta
great to have you on thank you so much
thanks and see